zdf heute live herzlich willkommen
in den verwüsteten hochwassergebieten im
westen deutschlands geraten die menschen
zunehmend an ihre grenzen
vor allem im aartal fühlen sich die
anwohnerinnen und anwohner alleine
gelassen viele helferinnen und helfer
können einfach nicht mehr
es gibt kein fließendes wasser müll und
lebensmittel ziehen ratten an die
solchen gefahr wächst und giftstoffe
heizöl und chemikalien bedrohen die
gesundheit
wir sprechen gleich mit dem leiter des
krisenstabs gehen aber zuerst zu meiner
kollegin marion geiger korrespondentin
vor ort in bad neuenahr-ahrweiler marion
wie ist die lage dort im moment also
heute haben wir beobachten können dass
tatsächlich sehr viel hilfe an rollt
also wir haben viel bundeswehr gesehen
mehrere feuerwehren aus leipzig dresden
freiburg fehlt thw und die sind
angekommen und haben angefangen auch
große arbeiten in angriff zu nehmen wie
zum beispiel brücken abzureißen und eine
sehr sehr gute nachricht für die
anwohnerinnen und anwohner hier heute
nachmittag gab es dann tatsächlich
endlich wieder wasser und insofern ist
er heute was vorangegangen aber
nichtsdestotrotz bleibt die lage
natürlich ganz ganz schwierig für die
menschen die hier vom hochwasser
betroffen sind und es ist noch unendlich
viel zu tun
marion du bist schon eine ganze weile
dort für das zdf vor ort und berichtet
du sagst heute tut sich was dass es eine
woche nach beginn der katastrophe wie
kann das sein dass solange nichts
passiert ist
also ich würde nicht sagen dass nichts
passiert ist ich meine nur das hat man
heute wirklich gespürt hat dass sich
mehr tut hat auch gestern hat man
gesehen dass jetzt immer mehr
wassertanks gebracht werden dass zum
beispiel dixi-klos aufgestellt werden
aber in den in den ersten tagen nach dem
diese flut kam waren es vor allem
freiwillige helferinnen und helfer die
den menschen hier zur seite gestanden
haben und wirklich mit angepackt haben
mit eimern und schaufeln und ohne die
wir gar nichts gegangen das waren
hunderte und da war ein emsiges treiben
aber viele viele leute hier haben gesagt
wir sind ohne diese leute werden total
aufgeschmissen gewesen und der staat der
es noch nicht mal dazu in der lage uns
essen und trinken zu liefern
denn tatsächlich ist auch die versorgung
von privatleuten organisiert wäre worden
und ich habe hier kennengelernt die
claudia petri sie ist anwohnerin hier
sie hat die flut nacht miterlebt und sie
weiß ganz genau wie das hier gelaufen
ist claudia können sie uns sagen wie war
das in den ersten tagen wer hat ihnen
geholfen
hallo also in den ersten tagen geholfen
als die gebiete hier noch nicht
zugänglich waren waren erst mal die
anwohner selbst also die haben natürlich
zuerst versucht aus ihren häusern
hinauszukommen
und ja wir konnten eigentlich nur
zusehen wie das wasser die treppen
wieder gesunken ist also wir sind ja
nicht mal zur haustür raus gekommen
und ja das erste wasser und schlamm aus
dem haus haben wir mit bilderrahmen
geschoben um überhaupt erst mal raus zu
kommen dann waren wir noch nicht auf der
straße also das ging dann langsam von
alleine zurück und man konnte auch schon
sehen dass das sich an diesen punkten
die sie auch gesehen haben die
einsatzkräfte schon teilweise
stationiert hatten aber sie konnten
nichts tun
wir mussten selber raus kommen und die
ersten
möbel und wohnungen haben ja auch von
also selber geboren und da war auch
erstmal von helfern noch nicht zu sehen
und dann ging es erst mal nur darum sich
selbst zu retten herauszukommen
wir hatten auch rentner im haus und die
mussten erst mal alle irgendwo
unterkommen bei für die ist das hier
keine atmosphäre wann kamen denn dann
hilfe an bei ihnen in der straße also ja
das ist das erste wandern die
angehörigen wie gesagt von den bewohnern
die dann natürlich ihre ihre mutter ihre
schwester tochter etc einfach sehen
wollten einfach hören wollten denen geht
es gut weil wir hatten ja keinen kein
strom mehr die akkus ging langsam leer
und man muss ein bisschen sparen konnte
halt nicht jede anfrage beantworten als
die leute hatten das schon gehört das
was ist und alle haben gefragt
ja geht's dir gut und ja man muss halt
einfach schauen und das erste mal
natürlich dann die angehörigen die
vorbeigekommen sind gucken wollten ob
ihre familie noch lebten und welche
unterstützung haben sie danach bekommen
also es sind ja viele freiwillige
gekommen ist sind auch einsatzkräfte
gekommen wie haben sie das erlebt das
verhältnis wäre es ihnen da zur seite
gestanden also ich sage mal so wir
hatten auf jeden fall glück weil meine
nachbarin ist eine schulleiterin an der
franziskusschule auf non wert und daher
hatte sie gute verbindungen zu lehrern
und schülern die sie daneben organisiert
hat also bei uns haben junge mädchen und
jungs und lehrer angefangen die wohnung
leer zu räumen die keller leer zu
schaufeln mit eimer und die haben auch
dann erst mal material beigebracht weil
wo lagert man seine schaufeln im keller
die waren alle weg und wie ist es dann
weiter gegangen das über welche tage
sprechen werde jetzt wo dann langsam mit
hilfe dazu kam also wir sprechen dazu
über donnerstag eben der erste tag
danach freitag samstag sonntag ich habe
auch ehrlich gesagt das zeitgefühl
langsam verloren ich muss auch mal
selber nach dem tag fragen weil man halt
man man ist den ganzen tag nur hier ja
und ja so dieser normale alltag der mann
hat das unvorstellbar im moment weil es
ist ja wirklich einfach
katastrophengebiet teilweise wie im
krieg teilweise wie auf einer müllkippe
wie haben sie sich dann organisiert also
wer hat ihnen geholfen wie ist das
verhältnis von staatlicher hilfe und
privater hilfe ja also als ich das mich
heute morgen schon fragten dann wollte
schon aus der ferne rufen 100 prozent
privat und damit unternehmen auf
eingeschlossen weil diese ganzen
bauunternehmer und radlader fahrer und
bauern die hier kommen die kommen auch
auf eigene faust die sind meines wissens
nach nicht von der regierung oder sonst
wen organisiert mittlerweile werden auch
helfer organisiert hier über die
kreisverwaltung da kann man sich dann
melden weil es auch viele viele
freiwillige gibt die kommen dann einzeln
und bevor dann jeder hier mit dem auto
kommt ist das natürlich besser wenn die
sich dann organisieren und auch wissen
wo sie die helfen konnten was sie
mitbringen müssen
vermissen sie das leer also das angebot
staatlicherseits also das angebot
staatlicherseits ist vorhanden also wir
haben ja mittlerweile thw feuerwehr
bundeswehr ist hier im einsatz
nach 23 tagen im ich weiß es nicht mehr
genau kamen die dann alle und sind
rumgefahren aber erst mal sind sie nun
auf und ab gefahren
und ja man hat jetzt so mittlerweile den
eindruck bekommen dass das ja das hat
oben kein kopf sitzt ja wirklich alle
organisiert weil sie sind der
verschiedene feuerwehren verschiedene
thw stationen und man man gibt jemanden
was mit was man braucht was los ist wo
noch hilfe benötigt wird und die sagen
nur wir nehmen's aufgegeben es weiter
und dann kommt halt einfach nichts
das können wir ja vielleicht dann gerade
mal den herrn linnartz fragen denn er
ist ja der kopf was er zu diesen
schilderungen von anwohnern und
anwohnerinnen sagt genau marion vielen
dank an dich und vielen dank an claudia
petri für diese schilderungen und da ist
er der kopf der das alles organisiert
und der wie wir gerade gehört haben
eigentlich vermisst wird thomas linnartz
der leiter des krisenstabs auch aus bad
neuenahr ahrweiler zugeschaltet wenn sie
das hören es ist nur private hilfe vor
ort gewesen am anfang die menschen
fühlen sich alleine gelassen
sie waren nicht da es gibt keine
organisation mann vermisst einen kopf
der alles koordiniert wie reagieren sie
auf diese vorwürfe
na ja gut ich kann diese vorwürfe
nachvollziehen
ich bitte aber auch einfach zu verstehen
dass wir hier ein katastrophengebiet
haben riesigen ausmaßes das sind über 40
kilometer drauf
auch wir mussten erstmal schauen die
helfer die zuerst vor ort waren die
feuerwehren die örtlichen feuerwehren
waren alle schwer selber betroffen
und als wir dann die unterstützung
geschickt haben nach und nach mussten
wir die zu führen viele wege waren nicht
mehr befahrbar man musste erstmal sich
zurechtfinden in diesem ganzen chaos und
dann auch natürlich die einsatz struktur
ist nicht einfach sind feuerwehren
bundeswehr tier wie alle nicht
ortskundig die muss man irgendwo
koordinieren das hat einfach eine
gewisse chaos am anfang gibt es bei
solchen einsätzen wir sind jetzt dabei
seit mehreren tagen das besser zu
sortieren
die gezielt in die einsatzabschnitte
einzuteilen
die verstärkt dann auch in die straßen
und in die orte einzubringen wir mussten
viele orte zunächst mal die nicht
erreichbar muss man erst mal sehen wie
man dorthin kommt
die wurden von der bundeswehr mit
helikoptern mussten die versorgt werden
das sind einfach so viele baustellen die
wir jetzt einfach nach und nach glaube
ich besser in den griff bekommen seit
ein paar tagen können wir viele massiv
kräfte hilfskräfte in die einzelnen
gebiete rein so dass dann auch die
unterstützung einfach besser wird aber
ich es ist einfach eine gigantische
katastrophe die hier passiert ist und es
fehlt einfach die infrastruktur genauso
auch für die hilfskräfte erinnert dass
die infrastruktur fehlt ich würde gern
einfach mit herz an dieser stelle ein
bisschen weitermachen und die kommentare
auch aufgreifen die
bei uns bei uns auflaufen erinnert warum
hat die hdd erst am sonntagabend um
mitternacht die einsatzleitung
übernommen
das hat damit zu tun dass in der regel
hier nach dem landesrecht die
kreisverwaltung die einsatzleitung hat
und als dann der landrat gesagt hat
bittet das land darum die einsatzleitung
zu übernehmen haben wir das sofort getan
wir waren allerdings schon seit
donnerstag nein sagt mittwochabend mit
in der koordinierung und haben dem
landkreis überörtliche hilfe krebs
kräfte zugeführt wir haben im laufe der
berichterstattung über diese katastrophe
von einem helfer gehört föderalismus
tötet die strukturen die sie ansprechen
die abstimmungen die getroffen werden
müssen sind die schuld daran dass in
deutschland im jahr 2021 fast 200
menschen bei einer flutkatastrophe
sterben müssen
nein das glaube ich nicht
es war einfach eine ein ereignis was so
unvorstellbar war und das mit einer
geschwindigkeit passiert ist glaube
nicht dass das was mit dem föderalismus
zu tun hat aber hat das ist doch sorry
aber das ist doch der der kern einer
katastrophe die kommt selten mit
ankündigung wir wissen auf hochwasser am
rhein oder an großen flüssen sind wir
vorbereitet aber dass man mich auf jede
katastrophe vorbereitet sein kann wie
auch immer sie geartet ist es auch klar
aber es gibt katastrophenschutz gesetze
und alarmierungs wege und technik an der
man viel vorher so aufbauen kann dass
sie dann wenn es drauf ankommt
funktioniert und da gibt es große kritik
zum beispiel wird die mangelnde
ausstattung des katastrophenschutzes
kritisiert und auch ihre behörde die
idee dass müssen und vielleicht erklären
die alge
meine dienstaufsichtsbehörde also quasi
die behörde die im land rheinland pfalz
dafür zuständig ist die entscheidet ja
wie die feuerwehren zum beispiel
finanziell ausgestattet sind wenn die
besser ausgestattet wären dann hätten
sie vielleicht auch schneller mehr
machen können in diesem fall gut dass
letztlich entscheidend dass die kommunen
weil das selbstverwaltung ist wir
fördern aber natürlich kann man jetzt
sagen wir hätten das noch mal anders
aufstellen können aber für die gefahr
ereignisse die wir bisher kannten haben
sie den grundschutz gemacht und wir
haben ja ein system was was von der von
der gemeinde rüber über den kreis
verstärkt wird um dann auch vom land
über an weitere kräfte überörtliche
kräfte verstärkt zu werden aber mit
sicherheit wird auch darüber zu sprechen
sein welche fähigkeiten wir in zukunft
zusätzlich vielleicht brauchen sicher
blicken wir noch einmal einen schritt
vor die katastrophe und blicken auf die
staatliche waren app nina die nach
recherchen der zdf heute keine
warnmeldungen für den landkreisen
ahrweiler abgesetzt hat ein technisches
versagen das offenbar auszuschließen
ich würde gerne von ihnen wissen ob der
landkreis das nicht eingespielt hat oder
haben die behörden das einfach nicht
genutzt
das kann ich ihnen jetzt ehrlicherweise
gar nicht gar nicht so genau sagen ich
hab mich das müssen sie möchte verstehen
ich bin seit mittwochabend eigentlich in
der lage und muss die lage nach vorne
arbeiten also die diese katastrophen
dinge und dafür sorgen dass die hilfe
jetzt ankommt und dass wir das
stabilisieren ich habe ehrlich gesagt
noch gar nicht so genau in die details
dieser nacht reingeguckt weil das im
moment für mich persönlich hier und für
meine leute in der npd nicht das thema
ist wir müssen jetzt schauen wie wir den
menschen helfen wie wir die lage der
menschen stabilisieren können
sie haben eben vieles am anfang gesagt
was uns hier drückt aus dass der müll
das ist die hygiene lage das ist die
wasserversorgung deswegen
kann ich im moment gar nicht genau sagen
ob ihr der landkreis etwas hätte tun
sollen so weit ich weiß aber das ist
jetzt mal sage ich deutlich erstmal eine
spekulation ist dass nina system ja ein
system vom bund was vom bbk bespielt
wird und die landkreise bedienen sich ja
voll cut waren und kaplan hat der
landkreis das weiß ich sicher ausgelöst
da gehen wir noch mal zu claudia petri
die bei mario geiger steht die hier
nämlich auch erzählen kann wie das war
als die fluten auf sie zukam
ja also herr linnert sagte ja eben die
nina waren ab und prävention sei nicht
sein thema das mag auch so sein weil er
wie gesagt kurzfristig für die
katastrophen fertigung eingesetzt wurde
ich kann dazu auf jeden fall was sagen
weil ich die mine app selber hatte ich
habe jetzt letzte woche gesehen dass kat
waren auch sehr viel gemeldet hat aber
wesentlich mehr als diese app die wohl
vom bund organisiert wie sie ja sagten
ich habe da keine informationen bekommen
ich hatte die meldung ergiebiger
starkregen wie den tag zuvor auch und
ergiebig da haben wir noch witze
gerissen das hört sich positiv an und
ich bin an dem tag an dem mittwoch um 18
uhr nach hause gekommen und habe ich
schon gesehen dass hier sehr viel los
war viele schaulustige weil die aber
schon sehr hoch stand war selber hier
auf dem radweg noch spazieren den sie
jetzt nicht mehr sehen können
ja und war dann die ganze zeit in
alarmbereitschaft aber wusste ehrlich
gesagt nicht was ich tun sollte weil ich
nicht bekannt mir war nicht bekannt über
einen katastrophenplan jetzt hier vor
ort was man tun soll wo man sandsäcke
herkommt ich bin an der feuerwehr
vorbeigegangen die hatten selber nur
einen halben meter die sandsäcke vor die
tür gestellt was soll man da als
anwohner denken wenn man in der ersten
reihe an der ahr wohnt die lautstärke
die lautsprecherdurchsagen lauteten
halten sie sich nicht den kellern auf
und verlassen sie tiefgaragen das andere
konnte ich leider nicht verstehen
sodann stand es hier auf dem spielplatz
das ist schon relativ nah vor unserem
haus und als ich mich entschieden hatte
mein auto auch wegzufahren stand es bei
uns im hauseingang und dann war mein
erster gedanke bei der nachbarin unten
im keller
und als ich die nachbarin aus dem keller
geholt habe robert ist schon in der
waschküche die war im bademantel das war
eine ältere dame und ja dann
funktioniert man nur noch das heißt
diese ganze dramatik dieses wassers die
kämpfe sie auch ja überraschend und dann
ging es halt nur noch darum die leute
aus dem keller zu holen
wir hatten ältere leute im erdgeschoss
ein 85-jähriger mann der war schwerhörig
und wir hatten ihnen erst nicht
rausbekommen und dann habe ich den
notruf gewählt und daher sagte zu mir
wagens auf wir tun was wir können und
diesen satz habe ich in den letzten fünf
tagen so oft gehört und wir tun was wir
können ist halt einfach in den häusern
nicht angekommen die schüler sind da
angekommen
lehrer sind angekommen freiwillige
helfer aus österreich mittlerweile und
das ist alles das was man hätte
vermeiden können und einfach die leute
anders gewarnt hätte mit den daten die
man hatte als regierung und anders als
vor fünf jahren wo in unserem keller
wirklich gar nichts war und das war
einfach dasselbe
und was soll man da als anwohner denken
wenn man wenn man bei einem
jahrhunderthochwasser niemand lebt da so
was schon mal erlebt hat was sollen die
leute denken die regeln das ins bett
vielleicht ist meine waschmaschine dann
weg erinnert sie haben das gehört wie
sie können bitte gerne darauf antworten
ich kann das komplett nachvollziehen
also das ist mir ich meine es ist uns
genauso gegangen sind
also wir waren schon alarmiert am
mittwoch dass da einiges kommt der
deutsche wetterdienst hat er sehr sehr
extrem auch gewarnt und auch die
landkreise wir haben
nachricht bekommen dass einige
landkreise ihre ihre einsatzleitung
schon hochgefahren haben wir sind dann
auch mal raus gefahren um uns ein bild
zu machen
wir sind selber sehr überrascht worden
von der geschwindigkeit in der das
wasser einfach gestiegen ist das war
jetzt nicht hier im art das war in der
eifel
das war unglaublich ja und ich kann das
gut nachvollziehen wir haben diese apps
und die waren die wahren for better die
waren vor starkregen vor hagel vor
gewitter und irgendwann müssen wir
glaube ich uns etwas anderes überlegen
dass das wenn es wirklich schlimm ist
die menschen das auch wahrnehmen und
ernst nehmen können
wir blicken noch mal gemeinsam darauf
wie die situation ist und wie viele
leute auch vor ort sind und gerade was
machen
rheinland-pfalz der landkreis ahrweiler
wo rund 130.000 menschen leben haben die
wassermassen besonders heftig
zugeschlagen
42.000 menschen sind direkt betroffen
128 konnten nur noch tot geborgen werden
weitere 155 werden noch vermisst
seit tagen sind orte nur schwer zu
erreichen
etliche schienen und straßen sind
unbefahrbar
allein 62 brücken sind zerstört
die bundeswehr hilft nun mit
behelfsbrücken zudem waren bislang mehr
als 35 hubschrauber im einsatz
doch den betroffenen fehlt es im
krisengebiet einer elementaren dingen
beispiel bad neuenahr ahrweiler die
stromversorgung in der stadt war bis
gestern erst zu 40 prozent
wiederhergestellt die
trinkwasserversorgung zu 20 prozent
um die hilfe zu stemmen sind neben
bundeswehrsoldaten tausende
einsatzkräfte im landkreis ahrweiler
eingesetzt darunter 1600 von der
feuerwehr 2000 vom technischen hilfswerk
800 von sanitätsdiensten sowie 1000
polizisten
ja es sind also viele da sehen wir aber
bevor wir mit herrn linders darüber
sprechen wie sie denn zu verteilen und
einzusetzen sind möchte ich mich an der
stelle sehr herzlich bei claudia petri
und marie & geiger bedanken dankeschön
für diese sehr emotionalen eindrücke aus
dem was sie erlebt haben vielen dank
nach bad neuenahr ahrweiler und erinnert
sich weiß sie sind im einsatz sie haben
einen einsatz zu leiten aber die kurze
zeit würden wir uns noch nehmen mit der
frage unter anderem wie kann es sein
dass so viele helfer vor ort sind wir
aber gleichzeitig wenn man im netz
fließt große kritik daran hört dass
viele auch wieder weggeschickt wurden
auch feuerwehren polizei züge die vor
ort waren aber die für die irgendwie
keine verwendung gefunden wurde und
viele die am nürburgring stehen aber
offenbar nicht abgerufen werden während
die leute wie wir gerade gehört haben
in den orten sitzen und dringend hilfe
brauchen das ist etwas was einfach auch
bei so einem großen einsatz auch
passiert oder passieren kann
wir haben zu beginn einfach wahnsinnig
auch viele kräfte aus dem bundesgebiet
angefordert da waren noch nicht ganz
klar welche einsatzzweck einfach da ist
nur damit wie sich schon einmal in der
nähe haben und die anfahrtswege und die
rüstzeiten also einfach einsparen dann
kann es passieren dass die einsatzlage
einfach noch unklar ist aber die schon
so lange hier stehen dass ich sie
einfach nicht mehr einsetzen kann
das war am anfang nun ist es das ist es
wichtig einfach zu koordinieren von hier
aus wo geht welche truppe hin wir sind
wir haben jetzt in den letzten tagen und
das ist auch so die kommunikation
zwischen den einzelnen
einsatzabschnitten im ganzen tal welche
kräfte sie brauchen wo sie hin sollen
mit dem bereitstellungsraum wirklich
stark verbessert so dass es jetzt
wirklich besser geworden ist sie spüren
dass auch wir haben jetzt massiv
einsätze einsatzkräfte in in die fläche
gebracht wir sind dabei wir haben jetzt
schon über 20 punkte geschaffen wo
anlaufpunkte sind wo hilfskräfte da sind
die ansprechbar sind wo wir verpflegung
konzentrieren wo wir auch zugang zum
internet gewährleisten die werden wir
weiter ausbauen in der nächsten zeit
eine frage noch zu den vielen privaten
helfern die vor ort sind wir haben
gerade gehört am anfang waren es fassen
nur privatleute die da waren
der vorwurf auch an sie ist dass die
privaten so viel mehr machen als die
auch ehrenamtlichen feuerwehren das thw
und die deren job es ist nämlich die
bundeswehr zum beispiel was sagen sie zu
diesen privaten helfern und wie groß ist
ihre dankbarkeit dafür dass sie sich so
sehr einsetzen und wie drücken sie
diesen dank vielleicht auch finanziell
aus die dankbarkeit ist wie sich gross
ich meine dass das so viele menschen
herkommen und anzupacken
ich weiß ja gar nicht mal wie viele das
sind die kommen einfach helfen und
unterstützen die menschen
sie müssen einfach sehen wie groß dieses
einsatzgebiet ist ich glaube deutschland
hat nicht so viele sage ich mal
professionelle einsatzkräfte um sage ich
mal das auszugleichen was freiwillige
hier
hier leisten können dann noch eine frage
im blick auf das wochenende soll wieder
regnen
die eine frage wie bereiten sie sich vor
und warum evakuieren sie die betroffenen
gebiete nicht
das ist etwas was gerade erarbeitet wird
deswegen bin ich auch etwas in eile um
zu sehen wir haben den deutschen
wetterdienst gerade hier ist eine
arbeitsgruppe
gebildet um die situation die lage
einzuschätzen und wir bereiten im moment
alles vor um jede und die möglichkeiten
zu haben sagt thomas linnartz der
einsatzleiter vielen dank nach bad
neuenahr ahrweiler dass sie sich trotz
des einsatzes die zeit für uns genommen
haben vielen dank herr linnert und ihnen
liebe userinnen und user vielen dank
fürs zuschauen und mitmachen und an
dieser stelle nochmal unsere spenden
tafel eingeblendet und der aufruf wenn
sie helfen wollen dann spenden sie die
bahn de 6 5 104 106 100 104 106 100
stichwort zdf hochwasser deutschland so
viel von uns an dieser stelle und ihnen
allen noch einen guten abend